it's that sort of feeling isn't it it's
like sticky
everything I see at my level are spirals
all right spirals you know the old ice
just think of our ice cream cone but
whether it's there that way you know
this way
spirals helicals spirals whatever you
want to call it but that and that so
like the hands just because you go oh
well I do it in Marathi Dory but I don't
seem to do it in this so I'm trying to
put it so that you start that
ingredients you put it into a lot of the
stuff yeah
you do and now it's sticky
it's because you've started the spiral
but then you've stopped it so I call
this a question mark because it goes
like that
you know you've got the dot underneath
this
comes here but I've got to continue that
spiral
in Tai Chi when we do Push Hands you're
never supposed to bring your hands in in
Tai Chi or else the enemy gets you
so Tai Chi taught me
keep it away from myself
but I have to keep this spiral going so
we're going to do that um
we're going to do that after the bike
because what you're doing is you're
getting halfway you're getting all these
bits the wrist is right for sheer Naggy
the wrist is right now for car guys and
then all of a sudden you're going
got it
all right so this is uh this is natural
spiral